[Music]
this week the california highway patrol
rescued an injured hiker from a mountain
near napa
the hiker was able to use his
smartphone's gps to let rescuers know
his location
but a new service is trying to make it
even easier to be located in the event
of an emergency
charlie dagger has the story three
little words may have saved the life of
teresa apps husband
all of a sudden he became unwell and
laid down and there was no getting him
up and
realized that i needed to call an
ambulance the austin texas native and
her husband had just gone for a stroll
on this
english beach when he collapsed but when
she called the ambulance
there was a problem as i was talking to
the dispatcher
she i said we're on the beach in
eastbourne and we're
kind of across from the grand hotel in
the west lawns and
and on the beach and and she said what
town are you in
wow and i realized she wasn't in
eastbourne
yeah and so i said i've got the what
three words out
what three words an app that pinpoints a
location
anywhere on the planet within a ten foot
square
by assigning it with a unique three-word
designation
teresa's husband fell ill right here but
how do you describe what right here
means
she used these three words supper switch
sheep the london-based startup is the
brainchild
of british entrepreneur chris sheldrick
we kind of had this idea that if you
divide the world
into three meter by three meter squares
you've got enough combinations of three
words
that you can name each three meter
square in the world with just a unique
sequence of three words
the rest was a straightforward math
problem simply divide the world
into 57 trillion squares
using forty thousand words with no
masks or social distancing you may have
guessed by now we started this story in
the
pre-pandemic days so let's start by
trying the app here
and what have we got normal chat cans
pretty recognizable address but now
let's try something
a little more remote like say the middle
of the mountains
of northern iraq yep there it is
mention siblings steeple
now for the real test what about the
battlefields of northeast syria
yep there it is although i probably
shouldn't give out
this location and back in london
they clocked exactly where i was okay
yes so it's mention
siblings steeple yep
are you sure yes why okay
then so it looks like
you were in northern iraq
why did you ask me if i was sure uh
because i didn't know if you'd been in
northern iraq were you in northern iraq
yeah i'm a war zone correspondent there
you go the app is free for individual
users and emergency services here and
around the globe
including the us however some critics
argue that a system increasingly relied
on by the public
shouldn't be in the hands of a private
company this is
a proprietary system
one that is owned and run by a company
and we never know what might happen in
the future
when we have those kinds of systems as
far as the aptly named
teresa app is concerned this app
is a lifesaver you might not ever need
it and hopefully you never will
but if you do remember that it's there
and
and it's just brilliant three words
happily ever after for cbs this morning
saturday
charlie dagetta eastbourne england
that is so sweet perfect i have another
three words
war zone correspondent that's right drop
the mic
you know he'd been at this a while
because of the various haircuts
by the way i downloaded the app and i
figured out where we are right
listen to this these are the three words
to describe like that corner of the
studio right
bands oh my gosh juices
proven wow hello that's where we do
dishes and introduce sessions and we
prove things
like cocktails
well
nicely done ed o'keefe